>> Laura: IT'S TIME FOR THE
ARBITER.
TWO ATTORNEYS ARGUE A CASE, AND
I, JUDGE LAURA, MAKE THE FINAL
RULING.
A JOINING ME NOW, OUR ATTORNEYS.
HERE ARE THE RULES, EACH
ATTORNEY HAS 30 SECONDS TO LAY
OUT HIS CASE, FOLLOWED BY A
REBUTTAL.
IF THE JUDGE NEEDS MORE INFO,
EACH OF YOU WILL HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL 30 SECONDS TO
EXPLAIN.
IN THE END, I WILL MAKE MY
RULING.
PERSONALLY DOCKET TONIGHT, IT
WAS THE FYRE FESTIVAL, SUPPOSED
TO BE THE MOST EXCLUSIVE MUSIC
FESTIVAL OF A DECADE.
CELEBRITIES AND MODELS PROMOTED
IT ONLINE INCESSANTLY.
>> THE ACTUAL EXPERIENCE EXCEEDS
ALL EXPECTATIONS.
ALL THESE THINGS THAT MAY SEEM
BIG AND IMPOSSIBLE, ARE NOT.
IT GIVES THAT KIND OF ENERGY,
THAT TYPE OF POWER.
>> Laura: CALLED THE FYRE
FESTIVAL.
HUNDREDS FLOCKED TO THE PRIVATE
ISLAND, MET WITH THESE LUXURY
ACCOMMODATIONS.
LOOKS GOOD, DOESN'T IT?
AND THIS GOURMET FOOD, A TOTAL
DISASTER.
THE FYRE ORGANIZER, THE FESTIVAL
ORGANIZER WAS SENTENCED TO FIVE
YEARS IN PRISON, BUT WHAT ABOUT
ALL OF THE MODELS IN THE PROMO
VIDEO.
OUR KENDALL JENNER, BELLA HADID,
AND OTHER MODELS COMPLICIT IN
THIS FRAUD?
30 SECONDS FOR YOUR OPENING
ARGUMENT, NOT GET THE TIME UP ON
THE CLOCK PLEASE.
GO.
>> OKAY, THE MODELS, THE
MILLIONAIRE MODELS, IN THIS
CASE, HAVE BEEN SERVED WITH A
SUBPOENA BY A TRUSTEE IN THE
BANKRUPTCY COURTS.
HIS JOB IS TO COLLECT MONEY AND
INFORMATION FOR THE VICTIMS OF
THIS FRAUDULENT BUSINESS CRIME,
THEY GOT PAID FOR THE WORK THEY
DID, AND THEY SHOULD BE LEFT
ALONE.
IT IS HARD TO BALANCE THE
HARDSHIPS IN FAVOR OF THE
MILLIONAIRE MODELS GET A QUARTER
OF A MILLION DOLLARS FOR ONE
TWEET, SO WHO DESERVES THE
FAIRNESS, AND WHO DESERVES TO BE
A CONVENIENCE?
THE MODELS ARE THE VICTIMS.
I'M ON THE SIDE OF THE VICTIMS.
I THINK THE MODEL NEED TO
COMPLY.
>> Laura: ED, YOUR TURN.
>> YOUR HONOR, FIRST I WANT TO
ENCOURAGE YOU THAT RUTH GATOR RT
ENCOURAGE YOU THAT RUTH GATOR RH
BADER GINSBURG.
HERE'S THE THING, THESE MODELS
ARE HIGHER BECAUSE THEY ARE
VACUOUS PEOPLE, THEY DON'T HAVE
ANY SENSE OF BUSINESS OR
ANYTHING ELSE.
THEIR JOB IS TO PUT OUT A TWEET,
PUT THEIR NAME OUT, THEY HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT IS GOING ON BEHIND THE
SCENES.
YOU CAN'T HOLD THEM TO ANY KIND
OF STANDARD.
THEY ARE BARELY CAPABLE OF
MAKING CONTRACTS BECAUSE OF
THEIR OWN --
>> Laura: PEJORATIVE.
>> COME ON!
THEY WERE IN FOR JUST THAT PART
OF IT.
>> Laura: SOUTH, THE REBUTTAL.
>> THE FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION
SLAMMED THE MODELS ARE COMING
OUT WITH ADVERTISEMENTS AND
TWEETS FOR THIS WITHOUT A
DISCLOSURE, COMPLIANCE WITH
FEDERAL LAW, THAT THEY WERE
ACTUALLY BEING HIRED AND
COMPENSATING.
THEY ARE IN TROUBLE WITH THE
AGENCY, THE BANKRUPTCY COURT,
THEY DESERVE TO COMPLY.
>> Laura: QUICK, 15 SECONDS.
>> THEY DID WHAT THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO DO.
THEY CAN'T BE TOLD TO ANY
HIGHER, THEY GOT THE JOB DONE.
>> Laura: RULING FOR SETH.
I WILL SAY WHY.
THE MODELS SENT OUT THOSE
TWEETS, THEY DID NO DUE
DILIGENCE ON THE FESTIVAL THEY
WERE PROMOTING, DO DUE DILIGENCE
BEFORE YOU GETTING YOUR MONEY,
KENDALL.
NEXT, GWYNETH PALTROW BEING SUED
BY A MAN WHO CLAIMS SHE SMASHED
INTO HIM WHILE SKIING.
KNOCKING HIM OUT, LEAVING HIM
WITH A CONCUSSION AND FOUR
BROKEN RIBS.
HE SAYS SHE DIDN'T STICK AROUND,
JUST LEFT HIM ON THE MOUNTAIN.
>> I COULDN'T DO ANYTHING,
COULDN'T FUNCTION, AND SO I GET
SO TIRED, I GO TO BED.
>> Laura: HE'S ASKING FOR
$3.1 MILLION.
IS THIS A VIOLATION OF RECKLESS
SKI PROVISION, IS IT REALLY
WORTH THAT MUCH IN DAMAGES?
30 SECONDS BACK ON THE CLOCK.
EDA, YOU MAY BEGIN ARGUMENT.
>> WHAT WE HAVE IS GWYNETH
PALTROW, AFTER SHE COMMITTED
THIS VIOLATION, AND THERE IS A
VIDEO OF THIS, IT HAS BEEN
PRESENTED, THERE ARE
DESCRIPTIONS OF WHAT HAPPENED.
SHE DID WHAT A LOT OF MOVIE
STARS DO, SHE WENT OUT AND
BOUGHT UP ALL OF THE WITNESSES,
HAD PEOPLE TO CHANGE THEIR
STORIES, THE PEOPLE THAT RAN THE
RESORT.
WE KNOW THIS GUY WAS REALLY
HURT, HE COULD BARELY SLEEP, HE
WAS REALLY HURT.
THERE WAS A VIOLATION AND SHE
HAD PAID FOR THAT.
>> Laura: SOUTH?
>> YOUR HONOR, THIS CASE IS
RIDICULOUS.
YOU CAN'T PICK UP SO MUCH SPEED
THAT HE CAN ACT LIKE SHE IS
SLAMMING OUT OF A SYLVESTER
STALLONE MOVIE.
HE SAID HE HAD A CONCUSSION AND
A FEW BROKEN RIBS, IS THAT WORTH
$3.1 MILLION?
I DON'T THINK SO.
I CAN TELL YOU HOW THIS MOVIE
ENDS, YOU NOT GETTING ANYWHERE
CLOSE TO THAT.
SHE SAYS THAT HE HIT HER, SO AT
THE END OF THE DAY, I TELL YOU,
HE IS NOT GOING TO WIN ANYWHERE
CLOSE TO $3.1 MILLION.
>> Laura: I'M GOING WITH ED ON
THIS, I'M REDUCING THE JUDGMENT
TO ABOUT $50,000.
JUST BECAUSE HE NEEDS ACTING